[Musique]
il y a plusieurs choses qui doivent être
faites le plus vite possible une fois
qu'ils sont venus m'arrêter
[Musique]
où sera terminée en moins d'une minute
on était à deux doigts de le mettre
derrière les barreaux si on n'a pas ce
témoin
manning ça va être relâché dès que le
paquet sera arrivé vous donnerez votre
témoignage et vous retrouverez votre vie
on m'a juste dit les vals paquet votre
nom moi je suis comme coursier ça suffit
pas
quel corps essaie de vous tuer
[Musique]
le témoin a réussi à s'enfuir je crois
que nous avons un problème on ne connaît
pas vraiment pas de numéro un mondial
pas de date de naissance
c'est un fort taux
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites bon
j'ai payé le prix fort pour en arriver
là ne me décevez pas sinon vous et tous
ceux que vous connaissez vous le paierez
encore plus cher retrouve à l'air
retrouvez le sucre
[Musique]
oui
vous êtes qui
je ne sais quel corsier
[Musique]